We’ve had our first regular council meeting
of the year for the February meeting.
It wasn’t a particularly demanding meeting,
but we did start the meeting with a moment’s
silence in memory of Karen Eastwood, who recently
died.
She’s a member of the Wooden-Sefton Community
board.
Also for Peter McMorran from Oxford who was
a past councillor and the last chair of Oxford
County Council.
And Richard Cocker who was one of our staff
members who worked for quite a long time with
the building unit.
We also acknowledged the three local recipients
of honours in the New Year’s Honours list,
so that was a nicer thing to be able to do.
The meeting itself, I guess there were two
main areas of discussion.
One was our submission to a parliamentary
select committee on a government proposal
to shift the responsibility for fluoridating
water from councils to district health boards.
None of the water supply in Waimakariri is
fluoridated, and in my time I’ve had very
little demand for that to happen.
Our preference is that it’s a national issue
related to dental health and it should be
dealt with nationally.
The other matter that we dealt with at the
council meeting. We looked at the question
whether we should have an independent member
of our audit and risk committee.
A number of councils around the country do
that, but in the end our council decided that
with the quality of our staff and the kind of oversight
that we can give as elected members – we
didn’t need to do that.